to be honest with the incense well I've
gone through it quite quite a lot over
the last probably
um
what seven years maybe like bad
um I think it kind of triggered with
that uh when I mentioned that
um car crash I mentioned earlier that
was kind of like a trigger too
it's like a bull rolling I suppose on on
the mental health side of things and
then probably about a couple of months
later I've never actually spoken about
this uh
in depth but um yeah and then it
gradually got more and more I uh our
daughter had been born and I was
worried about the man I was going to be
in terms of a father and stuff to build
a bad headline the times I've been going
to put it to bed and I'd be like
I'm I'm gonna be a bad dad probably I
can't do you know I mean I can't provide
for it maybe the way she needs to or
whatever like that and you stuck down
yourself with that then you have other
things and it all came to a head where I
was I was literally driving home one
night uh from London
um on a Motorway and I was just like
aimed at the end of the road and just
like let's go and
pull it
I'm religious so to me it felt like God
literally bitched like me and said get
home and and I did I like unless you
just I can't I can't remember the right
thing all I remember it going really
really dark really quickly
um but I got I got back and um checked
myself into into a therapy unit the next
day and that started to address it which
was and it's still and the ironic thing
it was on world mental health day
you know um I was Googling uh you know
mental health and all the top hits were
World mental health then I thought mean
yeah and then anyway
um and then gradually started to talk
some stuff out and then it's been a long
process it's not it's not by any means
like it gets done yeah and you can have
people stay all the time oh it's good to
talk you know I find someone talk to
someone you know and that's easy to numb
but the best way I describe it is
and if anyone's listening to this and I
understand what I'm talking about is
you're aware that many people go through
it but to you it feels like you're the
only one who is and I know finding that
you know and it's finding that it's
finding that that way to to reach out I
mean even even recently last week I was
I was in a really dark spot last week
you know
um through through some things that have
gone on and it's how you how you deal
with it I mean my my wife is brilliant
she's been brilliant with me and really
supportive and I've I've started being
uh
um actually a psychiatrist now so you
there's different obviously different
ways of treating them
you can have a counselor you could have
therapist you could have a certain a
psychiatrist it's just different
different tools to deal with stuff and
how to how to get back to yourself and
how to
I always want to make sure that I leave
the world in a much better place when I
came into it and if that if that's me
helping people do stuff in terms of okay
well he's he's done that he always comes
across a really positive outgoing guys
yeah and for the most time I am but then
you know it won't wear the mask you know
to stop themselves from doing doing
stuff and and sometimes maybe that's
where the
the
comic comes out shall we say yeah
there's nothing hides fear nothing hides
fear or tears more than Allah
you know you you do that and then you
you kind of have to have to live with it
and there's there's ways of doing it but
like I say at the time last as recently
as last week when
it just didn't feel like I was I thought
if I cry now I'm not going to stop
and it's it's just one of these things
you just have to
first of all acknowledge it I think
that's the most important thing is to
acknowledge it see it not that it's a
weakness to see that it's not something
that is
it'll be all right pull yourself
together
um and also the amount of mate who I who
I've spoken to about it
recently or or many weeks or months a
year have gone by
there and they'll say
yeah I know mate or or even worse
they'll say to me
you could have told me you really could
have told me then they get really pissy
but I didn't think if I mentioned it but
then it goes back to what I said is that
you feel that you can't you feel like
they wouldn't want to hear it
but I mean like even
uh like last week um
oh sorry yesterday last night I went and
met it with one of my oldest friends and
we've known each other for years and
years like you know you I was best man
at his wedding
um Godfather to his to his kids
and he's he's he's having a chat about
some stuff where he's going through and
we just went I went with her he lives
near the countryside
um and we just went for a walk for about
four hours and it is cold here at night
at the moment but you just you know we
still we found a tiny little Country Pub
we went in had a pint
went on another walk and just put the
work I wouldn't even say put for the
world to write we just spoke about stuff
which is going on and
it's literature they say you know a
problem shared is a problem at heart but
then you also get
I've done the exact same thing which he
set up really
because sometimes you're who you holding
yourself
um I always think who are you holding
at the leveler
you know we've uh my daughter and I have
got a saying which is be your bear
and she's at it then forget the rest so
it's that it's that thing about it
because they still being the best
version of you and then worry about
whatever other people are doing yeah you
know uh I'm so glad you opened up about
that because it's like you know oh well
so many people listen and they you know
you guys opening up or you know what
helps you James and then Oliver which I
was surprised I thought it'd be James
the depression
I'm just kidding no is that because I
like this is that because I like to go
outside at night with the telescope
yeah no but um you know Ollie to be
honest with you I I've had those moments
where I'm driving in the rain and I
remember
well I was doing a show and I had to
drive over this bridge and just thinking
I'm so tired I'm just not I'm not in my
right mind and just
what am I doing here I just I don't know
it'd be better if I was gone I I've had
those thoughts I'd be better I'd be I'm
a burden I'm no one understands no one
knows what I'm going today no one you go
with that because it just you you do
feel that isolate you do feel that alone
and you wonder why it's happening to you
and and what happens is with me is I
would be envious
of my friends going out and having fun
oh my gosh why can't I go out and have
fun
why do I feel like this why do I gosh I
wish I was that person they're just so
they have Clarity and they have you know
but you never know what other people are
going through
no and that's it I mean it was it was
funny when you say like the whole day of
fun thing because the thing what really
got the thing going with me years back
and say this is 220
2017 I think it is
maybe Are you seriously it was a while
ago anyway a long time ago now
um but yeah and I remember we went to
um
I was noticing I was going to places and
realizing that I wasn't
having fun
it was like going through the motions
going through the motions exactly
exactly exactly so we were we were we
were went to watch iax football team
play after that and I'd always wanted to
go to the you know see them see them
play and we were sat there and we were
guests of the club in the Royal box we
had Henry van dessert who is the
um like an amazing legendary goalkeeper
in his own right but also a like the
director of football director of the
club there chairman of the club or
whatever
who presented us with fine shirts from
the theme we met the team
and I remember just sitting there
thinking like
I should be enjoying this yeah yeah and
it you like honestly you don't let
yourself do it and then going back to
when we're in in the car
um that came from we were coming back
from playing a golf course which is like
one of these super duper Elite golf
courses you need to know someone just to
be able to play that that type of place
you know we
and I was driving home thinking
I don't know if I'd be able to play
there again I don't know if they'd want
me to play there again and you just kind
of start thinking about and then other
things start going through your head and
to the point where I didn't want to
I didn't want anyone to think that I
drove up there intentionally